imagine you are walking down the street
to do some shopping and suddenly a roof
tile lands on your head
[Music]
what is that supposed to mean you ask
yourself and you go inside the
department store from which the tile
fell off to complain
the owner of the department store shows
little interest in your Misfortune and
says that he cannot explain how it
happened
[Music]
of course you also have no idea how
exactly the tile landed on your head but
because you have a concussion you go to
a lawyer and Sue in court
what happens next depends on whether the
incident happened in a country that
practices civil law or one that applies
common law do you know which of the two
is practiced where you live
[Music]
let's say the whole thing happens to you
in Germany which belongs to the
Continental European legal system where
a civil law applies how does the judge
evaluate your case
she is looking for a legal provision
that fits your case in the German civil
code article 838 she will find the
general rule that a building user has to
maintain the structure and is
responsible for the damage caused if
parts of the building break off
the judge then examines the law she
checks if the defendant really is the
user of the building if he has to
maintain the building by law and whether
he had negligently failed to do so if
all those legal elements are fulfilled
the department store operator is liable
and you as the plaintiff who instituted
the legal proceedings will receive
compensation for the suffering caused by
the event
if you had taken your walk in the United
States which belongs to the
anglo-american legal system the common
law the judge would proceed differently
in the U.S the judge would instead look
for a comparable case such as the
English case of burn versus bodle from
1863 in which pretty much the same thing
had happened to a poor passerby only it
had not been a loose brick but rather a
barrel stored in the building
in this case the Court held the
department store owner responsible even
though the plaintiff could not prove
negligence on the part of the defendant
so what are the differences between
civil law and common law
the legal systems are differentiated
primarily on the basis of their way of
thinking
the civil law system is characterized by
thinking on the basis of general and
Abstract legal Provisions most of which
are laid down in codifications such as
the civil code in Germany the judge
works deductively by applying the
general rule to the concrete case a
technique known as subsumption
the common law system is characterized
by similar cases that happened in the
past the so-called doctrine of stare
decisis Latin 4 to stand by things
decided binds judges to precedence cases
that happened in the past that is why
the judge works on a case-by-case basis
and Compares them with one another if
the judge wants to deviate from a
previous decision the so-called
distinguishing is used to determine the
differences between the case at hand and
the precedent
in summary to determine wrongdoing and
compensation the civil law system relies
on the code of law interpreted by judges
while the common law system relies on
similar cases from the past what are
your thoughts which legal system is
better share your thoughts in the
comments below and tell us what type of
law is practiced in the country you are
from
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
take a look learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
if you are an educator check our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons plus
additional resources and classroom
activities